this is finnick o'dare finnick oh dare
have you ever wondered what lurked
behind the dazzling smile of the
capital's golden boy
if you watched the hunger games films
you truly only got a glimpse at this
victor's dark and tragic backstory
from becoming president snow's slaved
his twisted love story with annie
the books offer a look into finnick that
you wouldn't believe
so why did they cut out phenix backstory
in today's video we're going over
everything the movie's left out about
this district 4 tribute and how a
prequel about his life could be even
better than the hunger games
when we first meet finnick it's at the
opening ceremonies of the quarter quell
his shirtless and offering katniss a
sugar cube
do you want a sugar cube we're
definitely
not complaining about that scene but
while his exterior tells katniss he's
arrogant
just like all the other careers it's not
long before she finds out that that's
not at all true
don't trust one and two i'll take this
side you hold him off he may be charming
but there's a lot of pain hidden behind
his capital disguise
so what's the story behind finnick
actually becoming a victor
the films touch on it briefly but we
never really get the whole picture
for starters he was only 14 14.
he was mentored by mags and the reason
we always see him holding or using his
trident
is because that was the weapon that
helped him win the games he scored it
from the cornucopia at the start of the
65th hunger games
his time with mags also really shaped
him into who he is
after losing her in the arena katniss
says that he cried
all night but that was never mentioned
in the films
while his hunger games experience seems
pretty in line with the rest of the
career tributes
he's actually more similar to katniss
than the movie sled on
just like the mockingjay the games
didn't stop when finnick left the arena
president snow saw how much of a catch
he was in the capital
and began trafficking him to his
citizens there was nothing left to do
to let you play out your little scenario
finnick had
absolutely no choice in the matter snow
threatened to harm
all of his loved ones if he didn't obey
his orders
this is where his facade comes in he
puts on a show for everyone around him
so they don't suspect what's really
going on behind the scenes
but finnick did get something out of it
in the long run
instead of getting paid cash by the
capital people he asked for secrets
this background knowledge actually makes
his introduction to katniss make more
sense remember when she asks him
well then how do people pay for the
pleasure of your company with secrets
that's what he was referring to those
secrets
gave the resistance a huge piece of info
later on
finnick knew how snow had kept his power
for so long
snow was poisoning anyone who got in his
way while also
masking his crime by drinking the poison
along with them
he had all the antidotes of course but
the poison
left irreversible damage and that's why
he wears roses
to mask the smell of the sores in his
mouth we know
tmi it's also why he meets his demise
even though katniss changes her bow's
aim to coin
if phenix character is finally starting
to make sense after hearing his
backstory
you're not alone the film gave us pieces
of his character but never the whole
picture
we never truly got to grasp who he was
apart from being a victor
turns out his story might just be the
most interesting one in the film
his backstory of becoming a victor isn't
even the tip of the iceberg when it
comes to things they left out about him
the more people on our side the closer
we are to peter and annie
annie the love of phoenix life we do get
a few scenes with her
and a brief introduction but it's safe
to say the filmmakers paid her
basically no attention which is bizarre
because
she's not only important to finnick but
katniss and peeta as well
annie was introduced later on in the
series and that's mostly because finnick
kept his love for her a secret from
everyone that way snow would never find
out how much he loved her
however he declared his love for her
before he went into the arena for the
quarter quell
in catching fire my love
[Applause]
you have my heart for all eternity
boom just like that snow knew who she
was and used her against him with the
jabber jays
remember when finnick is tortured by
annie's screams in the arena
no it's not emmy
it was heartbreaking in the film but
when reading the novel you know
how much finnick has gone through to
keep her safe after seeing those he
loved punished
the book added an entirely different
layer to finnick and his relationship
with annie
finnick met his wife when he mentored
her through a pretty tough hunger games
besides being a career annie had a
strong alliance with the other tribute
from her district
and was forever changed when she watched
him get beheaded
graphic we know finnick was her only
comfort after she left that arena
all in all katniss and peeta are a
parallel of fennek and annie
they're all tributes have both been
threatened have watched loved ones pass
and then found solace in one another and
he quest as my wife from this day forth
however besides their wedding and
mockingjay we didn't get to see much of
them in the movies
there isn't even a hint at the fact that
annie keeps in contact with katniss and
peeta even after finnick is gone
in the novels she's always sending them
photos of their son
so not only was phenix full of
relationship with annie cut out
but their relationship with katniss and
peeta as well it would have completely
changed the dynamic
i am loving every moment with my son who
reminds me every day
of his father
even finnick's final moments weren't
properly represented in the mockingjay
film
while the rebels are on their way to
infiltrate the capital he gets taken
down by
mutts after fighting them off for the
others to escape
a hero till the end this happens in the
book
and the movie brace yourself what
happens
afterward in the novel is even more
emotional than what we saw on screen
when finnick is taken over by the mutts
katniss actually
watches him get beheaded before she sets
off a bomb using the holo
we know what you're thinking oh my
goodness just like annie and her fellow
tribute
exactly imagine if the films had left in
both of those stories ugh it would have
connected finnick and katniss even more
proving how integral of a character he
actually is
there are so many parallels between
katniss and finnick
almost as if in another world finnick
could have totally been the mockingjay
katniss and finnick were bonded in a way
that the movies never captured
after she loses him to the mutts she
spends a good while
thinking about moments she's had with
him and images of him with his trident
annie in her wedding dress and him in
district four while jay law did an
amazing job playing katniss
there just wasn't enough story behind
that scene to bring out how katniss was
actually feeling
or to show how closely bonded the two
were with one another
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the 76
hunger games
this all brings us back to our original
question
why was so much of phenix story left out
of the films it may not be the deep
answer you expect but one reason could
be due to time constraints
katniss was the franchise's main
priority and it was important to get her
story across the screen
in the limited amount of time they had
there's also the fact that finnex story
isn't the most pg just with the
trafficking and beheading alone that
would have had the film's ratings shoot
way up to at least a 14a that was a big
no-no for the filmmakers they needed to
make sure they kept that pg-13 mood
throughout the entire franchise
if they didn't half their audience
technically wouldn't have been allowed
to watch
it's just sad that in order to
accomplish this it had to be at the
expense of a character like finnick
o'dare
but that doesn't mean we'll never get to
hear or see his story
suzanne collins recently released a
prequel surrounding snow story
maybe a prequel for our district 4
tribute is just around the corner
how have we all been sleeping on one of
the best characters in the hunger games
with a backstory even darker than
katniss we're pretty sure a prequel on
his story could be one of the best
movies in the series
would you be interested in more finnick
content let us know below
make sure to hit that subscribe button
and we'll see you in another video